euh on va passer tout de suite au débat
du jour je vous préviens c'est un débat
qui va vous rendre complètement ouf Gill
verd je pense qu'il va partir en
cacahuète parce que je pense que les
chroniqueurs vont le défoncer on va
parler des greffes pendant les fêtes on
va notamment revenir sur les greffes qui
menacent les prochaines fêtes et qui ont
été proposées par l'organis
l'organisation syndicale sudrail à
travers une lettre envoyée il y a
quelques jours pour nous en parler on va
recevoir justement Éric Meyer le
secrétaire fédéral de sudraag féndéral
mononsoir il va nous dire si ces grèves
va tout nous dire sur ces grèves qui
inquiète déjà beaucoup de Français parce
que c'est les départs en vacances les
plus importants surtout l'année dernière
tout avait été bloqué les syndicats prê
dans l'otage les Français oui non
dites-le sans détour c'est parti
regardez
merci à un mois des vacances de Noël une
question est sur toutes les lèvres
aura-t-il des trains à Noël car sielle
n'a pas encore été actée une grffe de la
SNCF au moment des fêtes fait peser
comme l'an dernier la menace d'une
pagaille sur le réseau après une grffe
des contrôleurs je devais avoir mes
petites filles pour Noël je vais me
retrouver tout seul alors que les
syndicats qui estiment la hausse de
salaire des cheminau insuffisantees et
qui appellent à une puissante
mobilisation de nombreux Français qui
ont prévu de partir cet hiver sont
aujourd'hui inquiets menace de greffe de
laasncf pour les vacances de Noël les
syndicats prennent-ils les Français en
otage Mercier éc m d'être avec nous
secrétaire fédéral sudrail vous allez
faire greffe pendant les fêes Éric ou
pas B on verra
c'est on verra c'est c'est la direction
de la SNCF qui décidera moi j'espère la
fin du débat il y aura plus de nom que
que vous demandez vous demanderez vous
demandez 400 400 € par mois euh oui et
on trouve pas ça exagéré dans la
situation actuelle de de l'entreprise
pensz qu'il y a une chance de les avoir
parce que je pense ça va être compliqué
donc ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir grève
cet hiver non non mais bon il y a il y a
des négociations sérieuses à avoir ouais
mais euh il y a Philipp Philippe Bru le
drage de SNCF affirme que les cheminau
ont déjà bénéficié de 17 à 21 %
d'augmentation sur les TR dernières
années c'est faux euh euh c'est une
manipulation des chiffres c'est c'est de
la communication mensongère moi je mets
au défi la SNCF de poser sur la table
une fiche de paye d'un d'un d'un
chemineau qu' aurait bénéficié de 17 à
21 % d'augmentation hors ancienneté et
hors promotion professionnelle donc là
je vous dis on est mal
barré après éic forcément bah ils
essayer de de faire avec les moyens
qu'ils ont pour pour essayer de c'est
voilà ils ont pas d'autres moyens aussi
de de de se faire entendre combien G un
chemin au bout de com gag ça dépend non
mais ça dépend ça dépend le métier le
Chemino le Chemino baching le Chemino
baching euh non mais ça dépend ça dépend
le métier ça dépend la technicité ça
dépend la technicité du
métier non mais combien
c'est aujourd'hui enfin aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la SNCF elle arrive pas à
recruter voilà euh c'est clair
aujourd'hui en dans les régions
régulièrement on voit haut--fance Pays
de Loire on supprime des trains parce
que il y a pas les personnels de
maintenance parce qu'il y a pas les
conducteurs de train donc c'est bien
aujourd'hui que dans cette boîte il y a
un problème voilà en 2020 on a supprimé
le statut des cheminau voilà tout le
monde était youpi ces salot de Chemino
privilégié et cetera on le relève leur
statut seulement ce qu'on a oublié c'est
que pendant 10 ans avant il y a eu une
austérité salariale de dingue je veux
dire à la SNCF où nous on nous disait
vous avez le statut euh donc euh faites
des efforts en terme de salaire et du
jour au lendemain on nous enlève le
statut et on nous dit ben côté salaire
du coup combien gagne un Chemino au bout
de 5 ans ou 10 ans de carrière alors non
mais ça dépend des métiers alors
donnez-moi un métier je vous donne un
salaire raort à l'éducation nationale un
conducteur de train qui va refuser de
prendre son train qui va refuser de
conduire un train à Noël pour emmener
les gens passer Noël en famille combien
il prend par mois en a s'il a entre 5 et
10 ans de carrière parce que vous êtes
Délégué syndical vous les connaissez les
grilles de Sala ou combi il prend en net
avec un conducteur de train en début de
carrière 5 ou 10 ans voilà en début de
carrièreiss déàut carère non mais ça non
mais 5 ou 10 ans ça va dépendre non mais
ça va dépendre de ses conditions de
travail aussi je veux dire voilà
fourchetteandme oui a une fourchette
voilà un conducteur de train un
conducteur de train en début de carrière
ça va être de l'ordre de 2200 € voilà
net mais oui mais qui c'est quelqu'un
qui ne va pas dormir tous les soirs chez
lui qui va travailler les les weekends
un conducteur de train une base de 35 he
un conducteur de train un conducteur de
train c'est 10 weekends chez lui par an
le reste du temps il est au boulot je ve
dire comme une oui oui non
mais et en fin et en fin de carrière en
fin de carrière un conducteur de TGV
c'est environ 3500 € net par mois au 35h
oui ou au 35 oui oui au 35 he mais tout
le monde est au 35h
je dis 3000 € 35 he on pourrait le payer
plus on pe on pourrait le payer 4000
5000 moi je suis bien payé ici mais
faire la grève à Noël quand tu es payé
3000 € net je trous on nous sort
toujours on nous sort toujours la grève
non mais oui mais pourquoi Noë pour moi
c'est une prise
d'otage non mais prise d'otage
l'anniversaire c'était hier unera prise
comme à l'époque quand les gens avaient
fait la grève avec total ils avaient dit
que c'est parce que le prix de l'essence
était cher 2 € c'est inadmissible alors
on bloque les raffineries on bloque les
stations servicees et à l'époque j'avais
dit c'est pas pour les gens qui font ça
c'est pour eux la preuve ils l'ont fait
pour eux parce que l'essence est resté à
2 € ils font pas la greffe pour
l'essence à 2 € et là j'ai encore le
même discours
j'entends c'est un métier difficile hein
de conduire des trains je dis pas le
contraire les 14 weekends que vous
m'expliquez je dis pas le contraire mais
j'entends moi de de de mon Prisma moi
3000 € de mon Prisma moi 3000 € au 35h
quand le salaire médien en France est à
1800 € certains certaines personnes
combien 250 le salaire Médi en France la
moyenne des Français c'est
2005 j'ai pas cel moi j'ai entendu
100 TR sur 200 € en tout cas c'est pas
3000 la moyenne des Français donc je me
dis faites une il y a pas de problème
vos revendications il y a pas de
problème je suis pour je suis pas contre
les grèves moi je suis pour les
revendications mais je dis que prendre
les gens et dire aux gens vous n'irez
pas à Noël parce que nous on veut
quelque chose je trouve ça bizar alors
moi je alors je termine alors si le
conducteur de train son salaire avec des
super conditions de travail c'était
génial pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui la
SNCF peine à recruter les conducteurs de
train et qui manque 1200 conducteurs de
train pour pouvoir assurer le
transport on trouve pas dans les
dans une entreprise qui décide du moment
des négociations
salariales c'est les salariés c'est moi
c'est qui c'est le patron c'est le
patron si le patron il décide de mettre
les négociations salarial au mois de
novembre comment on fait mais vousit on
dit au mois de février on est pas
content direction préè
nég la direction elle préfère négocier
juste avant Noël ou juste avant les Jeux
Olympiques parce que comme ça elle a
plein de oui comme ça elle a plein de
oui comme ça elle a plein de oui comme
ça Dani non mais excusez-moi c'est on a
la même chose en juin en juillet donc
c'est c'est évidemment pour mettre une
pression vous en avez rien à des
usagers le service public pas vrai c'est
excusez-moi 15 grève en décembre sur 20
ans c'est c'est juste parce que vous
êtes plus malheure a 15 menaces de grève
il il y a une phrase de de votre de
votre syndicat vous dites tout augmente
et les cheminaux ne s'en sortent pas et
vous croyez qu'il y a pas des millions
de gens qui s'en sortent pas c'estes
millions de gens il sont où ils font pas
chier les gens ils empêchent pas des
gens avec la vie difficile qu'on a en ce
moment des grands-parents de voir leurs
petits enfants à Noël c'est monstrueux
ce que vous faites c'est c'est
dégueulasse excusez-moi et 15 fois en 20
ans je suis
désolé
la question du la question du pouvoir
d'achat c'est vrai qu'elle touche tout
le
mondecheonde c'est toujours vous qui
faites la c'est quand même bizarre c'est
pas toujours nous qui F qui faisons la
grève moi je peux vous citer je peux
vous citer des entreprises qui sont en
grève tous les jours je veux dire je
peux vous citer des entreprises qui sont
en greffe tous les jours seulement bah
oui je suis désolé ça se voit
pas se voit pas dire aujourd'hui la
question des salaires madame je sais pas
ce que vous faites comme métier tu le
vois
bienop vois bien qu'elle fait rien bien
la question je veux dire des salaires en
France mais est-ce que vous on parle
chiffres est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte des chiffres là le le le
baromètre du Secours populaire on a
passé les 9 millions de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté les les
restos du cœur vont accueillir vont
refuser des gens cette année et tout ça
c'est des travailleurs pauvres je veux
dire voilà aujourd'hui les les les les
prix ils augmentent de manière
démentielle je veux dire les les grandes
entreprises
c'est les salaires je veux dire
aujourd'hui les Chem c'est des salariés
comm les autres monsieur moi je suis
avec vous mais ce que ce que je déplore
moi dans les grèves à chaque fois c'est
jamais pour l'augmentation du prix du
billet c'est jamais parce qu'il y a des
trains qui sont en retard c'est jamais
pour les conditions des voyageurs c'est
jamais pour les trains ou les ou les bus
ou les métros surcharger c'est jamais
des greffes pour les usagers à chaque
fois c'est des greffes pour vous c'est
c'est ça qui est un peu ch quand on dit
un exemple le RERB le RB avec des rames
qui datent de 196 l'ugmentation du prix
jeich faire par la cour des compes très
mauvais
exemple deses vient de dire justement
qu' y avait un énorme problème d'entente
entre la SNCF et
laatp à cause de cette ligne qui est la
plus fréquenté d'Europe et aujourd'hui
il y a 2 milliards de bénéfices pour la
sncard 700 million pour votre
augmentation alors que vous savez très
bien que le gouvernement voudrait
répercuter cet argent précisément sur
l'amélioration
des
compr on reproche pas d'avoir des
revendications salarielles d'estimer
vous êtes pay vous l'tes peut-être je
sais pas mais mettez pas dans votre
sauce vous nous foutez dans dans la mise
à chaque fois à chaque moment où les
enants besoin de se retrouver parce
qu'on habite tous à des coins différents
de la France déjà vous payez pas les
transports vous avez de la chance donc
ça c'est le salaire
sal bien sû que si famille dansf dire
tout
mondeé ça c'est un avantage
impressionnant vu que on est oigé de
prendre beaucoup le train voilà c'est ce
momentl quoi est-ce que les forist font
pas la grève la Saint-Valentin les
poulesent des à
pâit arrê de le
bordel
après il y a pas de problème si si la
direction de la SNCF et l'État mettent
les négociations salariales à un autre
moment mais pourquoi pourquoi
systématiquement elles nous
mettentème c'est pas le NRE c'est notre
problème bah oui c'est votre problème et
vous nous foutez dans le vous avez pas
vous en tant que délégué syndical tout
le les les mouvements syndicaux qui a à
la CNCF vous avez pas le pouvoir de dire
en février ou en mars on on bloque on a
demandé cette anné pas pouvoir
pour à pour à l'appu on a demandé que
les négociations salariales se tiennent
au mois de septembre la direction a
refusé y a quelqu'un qui vous défend zen
et
ongle non mais g verd je trouve
inadmissible mes collègues qui pensent
uniquement leur petit intérêt
particulier de savoir où ils iront à
Noël alors que ces chemau sont héroïques
ils font la Greff pour tout le monde ils
nous conduisent vous prenez pas le train
vous
rigoler laissz le finir
finir ils sont ils sont héroïques ils
nous conduisent plus personne ne veut
faire leur métier c'est hyper dur moi je
prends le train tous les jours c'est la
galère pour eux les conducteurs les
contrôleurs les agents c'est normal la
SNCF 2 milliards 4 de bénéfices on veut
rien leur redonner mais ce sont nos
héros ces gens-là faites grève à Noël
faites grève à Noël je serai avec vous
sur les piitet et vous et vous et vous
mais vous pensez qu'à vous bande
d'égoïes ces gensl mais ces gens-là sont
merveilleux bravo Monsieur bravo bravo
mais ilut pas c'est de la
démagogie
Toutie cont c'est de la
démag jeis je
suisard il
faut pour aller au travail le matin sur
le
r tous les jours r tous les jours je
vois la galère et
quand
sal sal pas et l'éducationtionale tu CIS
qu' gag mieux les
ma quand tu dis des conneries comme ça
dis non je te vénère pas tu dis des
conneries il y a les flics qui gagnent
moins l'éducation nationale gagne moins
choisais bien qu'il soi tous à 100000 €
par mois ce serait
formidableour'
mais c'est facile de dire ah je suis
avec vous et à Noël je serai sur le
qu ENF arrête parce que toi tu te
changeras ton billet il y a pas de
problème en revanche les gens qui sont
là des petits salaires ils changeront
pas tu sais ce qui se passer et ben ils
pourront pas
partir aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui al aujourd'hui arrê arrêtez
d'être caricatural des problèmes de
salaire et aujourd'hui ça traverse toute
la société aujourd'hui a aujourd'hui
votre discour vous vous avez peut-être
pas de problème de salaire aujourd'hui
les salariés les salariés ils en on les
salariés ils en ont tout le monde le dit
Barom les salaires se TASS le salarié
les métiers utiles vous les avez
citéi Noël il est pas tombé aujourd'hui
on parle de quoi on parle d'un
courrier
G on parle
d'uner jamais rien pour toi ça j'avais
bien compris ouais pas
la oui oui là oui ça jeis bien compris
non mais alors il y a des gens qui
disent aussi vous oubliez tous les
avantages
sociauxquah vous payez vos billets ou
pas avec votre famille euh alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a on a le
droit
à H
alleretour de de TGV par an où on paye
une partie de la réservation
voilà et et tout ça c'est considéré
comme tout ça c'est considéré comme un
avantage en nature fiscalisé comme un
avantage en
nature voilà aujourd'hui est-ce que le
boulanger il paye son pain est-ce que le
commercial il paye sa
bagnole que le boulanger comme vous avez
un fort pouvoir de nuisance et que
l'année dernière ça a été absolument
cataclysmique est-ce que vous pouvez pas
dire à la direction ok nous on veut bien
négocier mais Noël on laisse les fr
c'est tranquille on bouge pas on fait ça
en janvier voilà alors moi je vous
j'étais à la réunion de négociation
annuelle la position de la direction
c'était vous signez on vous donne ça
vous signez pas on vous donne rien mais
vous savez qu'il y aura pas de grève de
toute façon parce que Clément bon il a
dit il faut absolument trouver une une
solution il a demandé à la direction de
trouver absolument une une solution et
donc le min et du coup et du coup si
nous on ne réagit pas est-ce que
clémment mon tout créau en disant il
faut absolument trouver une solution
mais vous allez trouver une solution
vous allez pas bloquer ni des Françis
est
aujourd'iousaniste pas crneau dis mais
suffit est-ce que Clément B réagit en
disant à la direction de la SNCF trouver
une solution oui je pense qu'il va va
faire ça mais ce qu' veut dire votre
action et la pression que vous avez mis
en menaçant les vacances de Noël elle a
une incidence
çaleectur le
résultat oui
% mais vous c'est normal c'est normal
mais mais ce serait Noël ou ce serait
une autre
date le le sondage serait le
même vous empêchez les gens de venir au
boulot la semaine ce serait pareil vous
empêchez les gens de partir en weekend
ce serait la
même moi de base je suis pour le fait
que vous fassiez grève je comprends vos
revendications je comprends le fait que
c'est un droit de faire grève vous avez
le droit la question elle est posée
est-ce que on est prend on est pris en
otage en réalité c'est juste le mauvais
moment et à chaque fois c'est le mauvais
moment parce que c'est avant les
vacances scolaires non parce que je
comprends les revendications c'est
juste l'année dernière l'année dernière
moi j'étais GV max ça veut dire que je
paye
onrouve
dans